so the US Outsource Market is estimated
to be around 1.5 billion dollars as of
2021 the largest in that business is
Tabasco which is made by mcelhaney a
family-owned company second is McCormick
which is publicly traded they own
Frank's Red Hot and they also own
Cholula which they purchase for 800
million dollars in late 2020 and then
after that we have uh Hui Fong which is
around I think nine or ten percent of
the market so they're still much smaller
than the the two biggest players in the
market but they have grown a lot in the
last uh two decades or so until now
so weapon Foods is a company that's best
known for its biggest product Sriracha
they're based in orindale California
they were founded by David Tran who came
to the us as a Vietnamese immigrant in
1979 and they're obviously their biggest
practice Sriracha that's what everyone
knows them for the iconic rooster logo
on the bottle with the green squeeze cap
they also have two other products that
they make one is called sambal Relic
which is very similar to the Sriracha
hot sauce but it's not Blended and then
chili garlic which is very similar but
also without the vinegar and the sugar
so what's really interesting about
hufong is that you know it's never done
any direct advertising it's only pretty
much going through Word of Mouth
initially its main customers were
chinese-american Vietnamese American
communities restaurants markets in LA
and Southern California and it's just
spread you know organically since then
you can actually sort of see its growth
based on the factories that it's had it
started out with a 2500 square foot
facility in Chinatown in 1987 they moved
to a much larger one he eventually
expanded that to around you know more
than 200 000 square feet and then in
2013 they moved to what is now their
main facility in Irwindale east of LA
that's 650 000 square feet they can make
up to 18 000 bottles of sriracha an hour
Sriracha is now everywhere right it's
really become a cold product and it's a
very unique example of a product that
has gone from being I guess fairly Niche
initially to being so widely used to the
point that it's now the third largest
hot sauce in the country according to a
market research from out of this world
and it's only behind Tabasco which has
been around since 1868 and then Frank's
Red Hot which is owned by McCormick
right a publicly traded spices giant so
for a company like we found that was
only founded in 1980 to reach that level
competing with a company that's got you
know more than 150 years of history at
Tabasco and and then a you know massive
publicly traded Corporation is is really
astounding
so David Tran he's the founder of lifong
foods he first came to the U.S in the
summer of 1979. he was born and grew up
in Vietnam during the Vietnam war he was
in the South Vietnamese Army he didn't
fight but he was drafted to it like
everyone of his age was at the time he
had actually started producing a hot
sauce using the chilies that were grown
on his brother's land in South Vietnam
after the war ended in 1978 there was a
lot of pressure from the Communist
Vietnamese government on citizens of
Chinese origin like David Tran and his
family to leave the country
and so he and his son and his wife as
well as other members of his family
ended up leaving Vietnam as refugees
they had to leave on different uh
trawlers he left on a freighter called
Hui fong in December 1978 which is
actually how he got the name of the
company eventually all that he brought
with him was a locket and 100 ounces of
gold that he hid in cans of condensed
milk so that they couldn't be taken by
the the Communist authorities he landed
up in Hong Kong after a brief Journey on
the freighter in Hong Kong he was at a
refugee camp for eight months and then
in the summer of 1979 he was resettled
to Boston however Boston was cold they
didn't really end up liking it that much
and his brother-in-law had actually
resettled to La he's mentioned that he
would call his brother or his
brother-in-law and his brother-in-law
had told them there were chilies
available in the markets in La which she
was not able to find in Boston so they
ended up moving to LA in January of 1980
that's when he started looking for
freshly grown chilies Jalapenos in local
markets in La he sold some of the gold
he brought with him to open up a 2500
square foot factory in Chinatown started
producing the hot sauce that we now know
Sriracha which was similar to the recipe
he had been making back in Vietnam in
the first two months of business in 1980
the company brought in two thousand
three hundred dollars
and he would actually sell the the
bottles of hot sauce out of a blue Chevy
van driving around La to different
Vietnamese and Chinese markets to sell
it
so if we found I think because it
started out as a product that was mainly
used by various types of you know Asian
restaurants and Asian communities in the
U.S it sort of grew out organically from
from those communities and those
customers it wasn't sort of you know
advertised or pitched to a lot of
different places you know it's it's used
by a lot of sushi restaurants around the
us there was actually a study made in
2015 by the NPD Group which showed that
nearly 1 in 10 households in the U.S
stock sriracha and actually higher than
that if you look at households uh with
people under the age of 35. it's also
kind of iconic right everyone knows the
rooster logo The Squeeze cap it's sort
of Dependable as a very spicy hot sauce
you'll find anywhere and it's
interesting there was a documentary made
in 2013 on Sriracha by Griffin Hammond
you know he talks all these people who
are big fans and a lot of people don't
even know that Sriracha is made in the
U.S right if you look at the bottle it's
written in Vietnamese in Chinese the
people have this idea that it's more
authentic because they might believe
that it comes from outside the U.S it's
not right it's a product made by David
Tran and his family who's he's American
but obviously he he came from Vietnam he
started making it in Vietnam it has that
authenticity and that simple recipe and
the ingredients that is used have never
changed the recipe has always been the
same and you know what you're getting
when you're getting Sriracha right it's
it's very identifiable and they focus on
that product right they also have
symbolic and chili garlic but they're
much smaller sort of source of revenue
for them
it's really mainly Sriracha that they
sell and they're so highly identified
with that product
over the years we found this how to deal
with some challenges including some
lawsuits uh shortages of Chiles and also
counterfeiters that have tried to sell
their product illegally one of the first
ones that sort of got a lot of news
coverage when the city of Irwindale
which is where their facility is located
sued huifong for basically odors that
the factory was emitting and you know
the center of going on for a little
while hoifong actually opened up their
Factory to the whole Community they
started doing factory tours eventually
the city dropped this lawsuit
it's interesting this this actually got
a lot of coverage around the US you know
Senator Ted Cruz actually asked we found
if they wanted to move to Texas to get
away from or window that didn't end up
happening and then another lawsuit that
happened was in 2021 the huifong used to
have an exclusive Chile producer up
until a few years ago called Underwood
ranches based in California and they
would produce all the jalapenos that Hui
Fong needed there was a lawsuit over
sort of the agreements that they'd had
with with Underwood ranches the lawsuit
has since concluded and what's
interesting about sort of the production
process is that the chili growing season
is pretty short and so if the Harvest
goes bad that means that they're not
going to have enough chilies to produce
the sauce for the rest of the year and
so they had all the production with this
one producer now they have multiple
producers I believe in California and in
northern Mexico so that's in the past
now but that was a major challenge for
them in terms of having to to deal with
that lawsuit and also on sort of how
they were going to get their their chili
production more recently in 2022 there
was a severe chili shortage in the
spring we finally actually sent out a
notice to a lot of their customers
saying that it was going to severely
impact their ability to produce any
sriracha and so there's a lot of news
articles around the us about the
Sriracha shortage I actually spoke to
analyst who was looking at Nielsen data
that showed that sales initially spiked
after this announce as people were
trying to hoard all the Sriracha that's
passed now they've been able to sort of
get back to regular production and also
the fact now that they have sort of a
diversified sourcing for their chilis
but when there's severe weather events
like happened in 2022 and there's only
one truly growing season that can sort
of severely impact how much of you are
able to produce for the rest of the year
David Tran by all accounts is a very
humble person he is fairly press shy he
has done a few interviews over the years
but what's really interesting is one of
his main phrases I've seen a lot that he
said to me also over email is that he's
just focused on making a rich man's hot
sauce at a poor man's price
he's not changing the ingredients he's
just trying to keep making the same
product and make more of it as long as
more people want it he's also said in
the past that his his American dream was
never to become a billionaire you know
he said in the past that he's perceived
offers over time to to buy the company
and he's not interested he just wants to
pass it on to his family and to keep
growing it as much as possible and
that's what's happened over you know the
last 40 plus years that the company's
been in business especially in the last
20 years the company's grown so much in
some years even they've grown even by
around 20 percent uh each year in some
years it's this phenomenal growth and a
very humble backstory right an immigrant
Refugee from Vietnam built this company
grew it organically and is not
interested in in selling it or bringing
out new products or changing the recipe
that has brought the company and the
family so much success
foreign